Okay. Good afternoon, everyone.
On behalf of my co-chair, Ling Kai,
I would like to start this session. My name is Christoph Kuiper.
I'm from Aachen, Germany. Ling Kai is from Duke
University, and we are very
much looking forward to share this session.
And we have seven speakers on the
topic of
transcriptional regulation and cell fate decision in cancer.
And I would, without further ado, would like to call up the
first speaker,
Riley Walter, who will talk on SOX2 as a master
regulator of classical squamous cell carcinoma.
Okay. Hi, everyone. Thank you so much for
being here today, and thank you to the co-chairs and
for AACR for inviting me to give this talk.
I'm really excited to be here.
I have nothing to disclose.
So I study squamous cell carcinoma, or SCC, which is
a major global health burden that results in over one million deaths per
year. An SCC can arise from many tissues of origin,
including the cervix, esophagus, head and neck, and lung.
And current treatments for SCC are aggressive and
invasive, including surgery, chemotherapy, and radiation.
And what's particularly concerning is that there's been very limited
success with current immunotherapies and targeted therapies, which
highlights that there's a lot of room for growth and improvement in treating this
aggressive cancer type. And if we want to improve
treatments, we need to first better understand the underlying
molecular vulnerabilities.
So SCC has a lot of complex genetic
heterogeneity.
And the Hayes group at UNC and later the
Cancer Genome Atlas Consortium were working to try to better
subclassify these tumors, and they decided to use differential gene
expression and ultimately found four subtypes of
SCC: atypical, classical, mesenchymal, and
basal. And with the onset of single-cell sequencing
technologies, they realized that the mesenchymal subtype of tumors were largely
comprised of immune cells and fibroblasts.
So there's three main subtypes recognized today: atypical, classical, and
basal. And though this data is from head and neck SCC, these
subtypes strongly correlate with those found in lung squamous
cancers as well as esophageal squamous cancers.
And this leads me to the question of what are the drivers of these SCC
subtypes?
So one hallmark of squamous cancers at large is
amplification of the chromosome 3q.
So when we break down TCGA patient copy number
data into subtypes: atypical, basal, and classical, we
can see that all of these subtypes harbor
arm level 3q amplification. However, when we zoom in
closer to the 3q locus, we can see one
clear focal amplification that is found only in the classical subtype,
and this occurs at the gene locus for the transcription factor SOX2.
And so because we saw this selective focal amplification at the SOX2
locus, we wanted to know if maybe there was some sort of selective
dependency on SOX2 and/or other transcription factors.
So we turned to the DepMap Gene Effects database and saw right
away that only in the classical subtype do they have
a strong dependency on SOX2 for their growth and
proliferation.
And this leads me to hypothesize that SOX2 is a master regulator of the
classical subtype of squamous cell carcinoma.
So the model system that I used to generate all of the data in this talk today
are two SCC cell lines. And I validated these findings
in other cell lines, but for time and simplicity, we'll just focus on these
two. So we have Kyse-140, which is a SOX2 high,
more classical-like cell line, and Bhy, which is SOX2 low and more
basal-like. And in Bhy, the basal-like, we can
overexpress SOX2 under a doxycycline-inducible promoter.
And then in Kyse-140, the SOX2 high, we can knock down SOX2
expression using CRISPRi or CRISPR inhibition.
And because SOX2 is a transcription factor that can bind to DNA and
activate gene expression, we wanted to know if SOX2 could regulate the
classical SCC gene signature. And these
genes are those that are upregulated in the classical subtype of
tumors from TCGA compared to atypical or basal.
And a pathway analysis on this gene signature includes many interesting pathways
like reactive oxygen species, glycolysis, and xenobiotic
metabolism.
So when I performed RNA sequencing on the overexpression and
knockdown model, we saw that when SOX2 is overexpressed, there's a
significant upregulation of the classical SCC gene signature,
and when SOX2 is knocked down, there is a significant downregulation.
Now, we wanted to dive into the underlying mechanism for this
dependency. And it's known that SOX2 can act as a pioneer
factor that remodels and binds nucleosomes directly in stem cells in
developmental contexts, but we weren't sure if that was happening in SCC because
many of the binding partners, like Oct4, are not expressed in these cells.
So I performed ATAC and SOX2 ChIP sequencing in my knockdown
model and found that there were thousands of sites that lose
accessibility upon SOX2 knockdown, and that these
sites that lose accessibility are preferentially bound by SOX2 and exhibit the
strongest SOX2 binding intensity, leading us to conclude that SOX2 binding
is necessary for maintaining chromatin accessibility at these
sites.And when we do the converse experiment where we
overexpress SOX2 in BHY,
we can see again thousands of sites that gain accessibility.
And zooming into these gained de novo accessible regions,
we can see a lot of strong SOX2 binding and
also strong SOX2 binding and accessibility in
Kwyz140, which is the classical model, leading us to conclude that
SOX2 overexpression is sufficient to drive chromatin
accessibility.
So we now know that SOX2 binds and maintains
chromatin accessibility at thousands of loci in the genome, but how does this
relate back to gene expression?
Another finding from the SOX2 ChIP-sequencing analysis is that SOX2
predominantly binds to enhancer elements rather than promoters.
So when we wanted to try to identify the direct target genes of SOX2 binding
sites, we used a method called HiChIP, which captures
enhancer-promoter interactions or loops to more precisely link
SOX2-bound enhancers to the promoters of their target genes.
And in this example here at the NOX4 gene locus, you can see in the top track
SOX2 ChIP-sequencing binding sites.
There are lots of strong interactions denoted by the darker green color
between SOX2-bound enhancers and the promoter of this gene.
But when we knock down SOX2, those interactions are lost or
decrease, and this happens across all SOX2 direct target
genes, which not only increases our confidence that this list
we have is direct targets but also
tells us the importance of SOX2 for maintaining these interactions.
So far, I've showed evidence that SOX2 directly regulates accessibility,
enhancer-promoter loops, and gene expression of the classical gene
signature. But how is this gene signature helping the classical cells or
giving them some fitness advantage?
So I performed another pathway analysis on this list of SOX2
direct target genes and again saw enrichment of many
oxidative stress-related pathways like hypoxia,
glycolysis, xenobiotic metabolism, and apoptosis.
And something that these gene pathways have in common is
ferroptosis, which is a form of pre-programmed cell death that
occurs when there's an accumulation of peroxidized lipids.
And looking even closer at this list of SOX2 direct targets, we
see several suppressors of ferroptosis that are upregulated by
SOX2, including GPX2, GSR,
AKR1C3, SLC25A10.
And another piece of data that I have was that classical
SEC cells are more resistant to this drug, an
inducer of ferroptosis, ML162. So these cells are
more resistant
than the basal or atypical.
And this, combined with the upregulation of ferroptosis
suppressors and those other oxidative
stress-related pathways, leads me to hypothesize that SOX2
mediates resistance to ferroptosis in classical SEC.
And so to test this, I performed C11 BODIPY staining in
SOX2 knockdown cells. And the C11 dye is a pH sensor that
turns from red to green in the presence of oxidized lipids.
And so this kind of shift that we see in the
SOX2 knockdown cells to have more green indicates that there's
more peroxidized lipids that form in cytoplasm
after ML162 treatment.
And I also measured cell death using an Annexin 5 and 7-AAD
staining in classical cells with and without ML162 treatment
and saw a significant increase in early apoptosis and almost
twice as much late apoptosis in SOX2 knockdown cells than
controls. And an important caveat of this assay is that it cannot
distinguish between ferroptosis and apoptosis, but I do still
think these findings suggest some sort of involvement of SOX2 in
ferroptosis.
So in summary, today, I've told you that SEC can be
classified into three molecular subtypes, classical, basal, and
atypical, all with unique genomic profiles and vulnerabilities.
And that classical SEC displays a focal amplification of the SOX2
locus and a selective dependency on SOX2 for growth
and proliferation.
SOX2 drives expression of the classical gene signature by regulating
chromatin accessibility and enhancer-promoter interactions.
And finally, SOX2 target genes could be involved with the mediation of
ferroptosis resistance.
I'd like to thank my lab, especially my advisor, Zhao Yang, and Yue-Chan Song,
who's the postdoc that has performed a lot of TCGA analysis I
presented. I'd like to thank my collaborators for their help with the
ferroptosis arm of my project, my funding, my F31 HCI
Travel Award for allowing me to be here.
And I want to give a shout-out to my lab mate, Emily Wilson, who's presenting a
poster on Wednesday about the dual enhancer-promoter function of alternative
promoters.
Thank you very much. So this paper is open for discussion.
Are there any questions?
Maybe I can start with one. So
SOX2 as a transcription factor is also involved in gene regulation
of fetal programs. Could you maybe speculate
how much of that is recapitulated with the
SOX2 phenotype in this cancer?
Yeah. SOX2 is definitely known to be a strong regulator in development and
fetal programs. I've done a principal component
analysis of SOX2 binding in SEC cells versus human
embryonic stem cells, and they do seem to have very different binding profiles,
and I think a lot of that could be due to expression of cofactors.
I briefly mentioned this, but other
stem... binding partners of SOX2, like Oct4, are not
expressed in the SEC cell lines we see here.
So I think that a lot of the difference in binding and genomic
programs could be due to that.
Okay. Thank you very much.
Maybe I'll ask another question. So the loss of
SOX2 will induce both apoptosis and ferroptosis?
It seems like there is some ferroptosis, or some
apoptosis in that last slide in just normal
SOX2 knockdown cells without any ML162.
There is about twice as much apoptosis in those cells.
However, it was 2% compared to 1% in the control
cells. So I think there could definitely be both
apoptosis and ferroptosis happening, but maybe the
advantage that SOX2 is giving these classical
subtype of cells is it's helping them kind of resist this
oxidative stress more.
Have you ever tried any of the inhibitors in label, like ferroptosis
inducers?
Not yet, but we're definitely thinking about it.
Thanks.
I have a question. So Riley, when you knock out SOX2,
do you actually get cells that will grow long-term in tissue culture that
are completely SOX2 deficient? And if so, do they show a change
in cell morphology? I noticed the EMT was on your list, but do they
actually assume a more epithelioid type morphology?
Yeah. So we are able to culture SOX2 knockdown cells
for a long period of time, like about two weeks or so.
And I do not see any changes in morphology in the
SOX2 knockdown. And similarly, when I overexpress SOX2 for
about two weeks or more, I do not see any changes in morphology there as
well. I know that EMT keeps showing up in these lists, and I'm
curious about it, but because we don't see the actual change in morphology,
we're still considering it, but it's not our favorite hypothesis right now.
Okay. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
All right.
Are there any other questions? Then thank you again.
Let's move to the next speaker. Please come up to the
stage, Amin Sabit.
Thank you.
Yep. Hi, everyone. I'm Amin Sabit.
I'm a part of the Charlie Ruden lab at MSK, and it's an honor to
be in front of you here and presenting my work, which is focused on
FOXP2B as a driver of neuroendocrine transformation in the lung.
So no disclosures as well. And lung
cancer, it's the leading cause of cancer-related mortality
worldwide, and it's
broadly divided into non-small cell, which comprises
the far great majority of cases, and the remaining
15% are small cell lung cancer. And
non-small cell lung cancer is further divided into lung adenocarcinoma or
LUAD, small cell carcinoma, as we just heard, and large
cell carcinoma. And while LUADs or lung
adenocarcinoma is the most common subtype of
lung cancer,
it is usually driven by activating mutations in
oncogenetic drivers, especially in MAP kinase pathway, and therefore
has good targeted therapies, while small cell is the most aggressive
subtype of
lung cancer, and it's usually driven by near
universal loss of P53 and Rb, as well as by
expression of lineage-defining master transcription factors
like ASCL1, NEUROD1, and PAX2F3, and also
is characterized by strong expression of neuroendocrine markers
like synaptophysin, chromogranin, and CD56.
Lung adenocarcinoma can actually undergo histologic transformation to small cell
in a process known as neuroendocrine transformation.
And while this is best characterized in EGFR mutant setting under
TKI targeted therapies, where around about 15%
of resistance mechanisms of patients
are due to histologic transformation,
this is not only unique actually to EGFR mutant LUADs and is
observed in EGFR wild type settings like KRAS and
ALK and ROS and RET fusion, and also can be seen
independent of targeted therapies.
Also, neuroendocrine transformation is not unique to the lung.
It's observed in other
cancer contexts, specifically in the prostate where it's really well
characterized and studied.
And as I mentioned with de novo small cell, where
it's a requirement to have P53
and Rb inactivated or lost, this is the same for
transformed small cell. However, it is not sufficient to drive
transformation, and it's believed that
transcription and epigenetic reprogramming are required
to drive transformation. However,
what exactly is the cause of neuroendocrine transformation
on top of P53-Rb loss, as well as also it's believed that
MYC and AKT activation might also be required, but none of these
are sufficient to drive transformation.
So we wanted to know what are further alterations
that are needed to drive small cell transformation in
EGFR mutant LUADs or the triple mutant context with
P53-Rb loss and EGFR mutation. And to answer that, we
wanted to leverage transcriptomic analysis on transforming
clinical samples,
in the hope of identifying novel candidate
drivers of neuroendocrine transformation.
And luckily in the lab,
Joe Chan and Alvaro, through over multiple years, were able to
gather a large cohort of transformed
patient samples and PDXs, and proceeded to do single-cell
RNA-seq on... on the cohort, as well as
never transformed triple mutant LUADs, as
well as de novo small cell lung cancer.
And then also, we're able to further define transforming LUAD,
which is the lung adenocarcinoma compartment in mixed
histology tumors. I forgot to mention that transformed small cell usually
presents as mixed histology tumors.
It will be retaining some of the original LUAD features, as well as the
neuroendocrine population.
And then transforming small cell is the neuroendocrine
compartment of combined histology tumors or post
transformation samples. And by doing differential gene
analysis on the different groups, like LUAD versus transforming
LUAD, and transforming LUAD and transforming small cell, as well as
de novo small cell and transformed small cell,
we hope to see genes that are commonly upregulated through
the transformation pathway.
And then we also wanted to specifically focus on transcription factors
or epigenetic regulators that have been implicated in lineage plasticity or
driving neuronal programs. And then once
we identify candidate drivers, we wanted to validate them in
vitro in our two EGFR mutant cell lines,
PC9 and H1975, and then we would proceed either with the parental cell
lines or induce p53 and Rb inactivation by transducing them
with CYW, which is a plasmid with a dominant negative
p53 and shRNA against Rb, and then we would
overexpress our gene of interest and then evaluate neuroendocrine markers
by Western blot.
And here, just showing
specifically one of the comparisons, de novo small cell to transforming small cell,
where we hope to identify drivers that are unique to transformation.
And in this volcano plot in the top right, you see genes that are
upregulated in transformed small cell versus de novo small cell.
And this is where we initially identified FOX2B as among
one of the most upregulated genes, specifically in transformed small cell.
And the reason we got excited about FOX2B was not
because only it's highly expressed in many of the cluster
UMAP in transformed small cell, and we don't really see expression in de novo
small cell, but also because it's an important
transcription factor in neuronal development, specifically in neural crest cells in
early development, and also it's been shown to be an
oncogenic driver in neuroblastoma, which is a neuroendocrine
tumor as well. So that got us really excited about FOX2B.
And then further computational analysis done in the lab by Joe
and
Mamie showed that among the differentially expressed genes in transformed
small cell as opposed to de novo small cell, FOX2B was among the most
associated with neuroendocrine high signature, as well as least
associated with EGFR signaling. And pathway enrichment
analysis for FOX2B positive versus negative clusters showed high
enrichment of neuronal and neuroendocrine programs in the FOX2B
positive clusters. So then we proceeded
to validate FOX2B as a driver in
our
LUAD EGFR mutant cell lines I mentioned earlier, so
H1975 and PC9,
in the parental and with p53/Rb loss.
And then when we overexpressed FOX2B, one of the early things we saw
was a marked decrease in EGFR signaling.
As we can see here, not only total EGFR, but phospho-EGFR or
active EGFR.
And also we did see some induction of neuroendocrine markers like
synaptophysin, chromogranin, and most importantly, ASCL1, specifically
here actually in the p53/Rb loss context.
And this was highly reproducible across different replicates.
So we were excited about this. However, we did not actually
see histologic transformation or neuroendocrine markers induction on the
level of endogenous small cell lung cancer.
So then we next wondered whether if we inactivate
REST, which is a known master suppressor of neuronal
programs, since REST is active in
lung adenocarcinoma, whether we would be able to drive full histologic
transformation or induction of much stronger neuroendocrine
markers. And indeed, when FOX2B was overexpressed
combined with REST inhibition, we saw enrichment in neuroendocrine
marker induction, and also worth pointing out that REST
at baseline as well is able to induce neuroendocrine
markers. But this is enriched when FOX2B is
overexpressed.
Next, we
did single-cell RNA seq analysis on our
in vitro models of EGFR mutant LUADs with or
without FOX2B overexpression, and Mamie did the single-cell RNA seq analysis, and
here showing across the UMAP that the clusters that were
highest on FOX2B show clearly lower levels
of EGFR signaling. And usually when we overexpress FOX2B,
we see the cells being very stressed, which makes sense since they are
having a reduction in their main oncogenetic drive.
We also-- Oh, sorry. Yeah. We also proceeded to do
FOX2B ChIP-seq, and we were able to see nice binding of
FOX2B at the EGFR locus, in the promoter, and
throughout the gene body. So it is likely that FOX2B is
preventing EGFR transcription, and that's how it's
leading to lower levels of EGFR signal.
Also wanted to point out that FOX2B induction of neuroendocrine
markers is not unique to
EGFR mutant lung adenocarcinoma only, but we are also able to
observe it in other LUAD-driven contexts.
So when we overexpressed FOX2B in two KRAS-driven cell lines,
we were able to see induction of different neuroendocrine
markers.As well as also in
ALK-driven LUAD in one cell line, we were able to see
induction of neuroendocrine markers and a decrease in total ALK.
When I was practicing, I didn't go through the slide as quickly as now, but
yeah. So I had removed a lot of things actually, so maybe the discussion would be a
bit longer. But yeah, this brings me to future directions.
So we are currently working on validating the mechanism by which
FOX2B induces neuroendocrine markers,
and also, we're working on knocking out FOX2B in transformed
small cell line. So we did knock out FOX2B in...
There are two endogenous small cell lines, a cell line that express
FOX2B, and when we knocked out FOX2B in them,
we did not see a decrease in neuroendocrine markers.
However, we would like to see if FOX2B is only
important for maintenance of neuroendocrine markers in the transformed setting.
It's been a bit of a challenge to
work with models with transform cells that express
FOX2B. In our cohort, actually, the
FOX2B was expressed more in the patient samples than the PDXs.
And then by the time we tried to derive cell lines from the
PDXs, usually FOX2B is silenced over time.
However, we have identified a cell line that
expresses FOX2B and is transformed.
However, also, we do see silencing of FOX2B over time.
Also, I haven't shown here, but we're currently working on in vivo
xenografts of our cell lines with FOX2B overexpression.
We have also not been able to drive histologic transformation or a
clear induction of neuroendocrine markers
with our current in vivos, but we have not tried the combination with REST
inhibition plus FOX2B overexpression.
And also, I haven't... Yeah. I would say that's it for
now. And yeah. I would like to thank
my lab, the Rudin Lab, especially my mentors, Charlie, Esther, and Joe,
as well as Mimi, who have done a lot of the computational work,
and everybody else in the lab, and happy to take questions.
Thank you for the presentation. Now we're open to discussion.
Go ahead.
Yeah, really nice work. I'm pretty intrigued by this sort of inverse
relationship between FOX2B and EGFR activity.
Given that this transformation arises when you're under EGFR inhibition,
typically,
can you speculate a little bit on when FOX2B might arise in that
trajectory in the clinic? And would you expect to see FOX2B
induced by acute EGFR inhibition?
Sorry, what was the last part? I didn't hear.
Would you expect the EGFR TKIs to directly induce
FOX2B, and then that to further repress EGFR?
That could be definitely the case.
However, when we treat with TKIs in vitro, like with
osimertnib, we don't see induction of FOX2B.
We do see some slight induction of neuroendocrine markers, but
it is kind of known that for small cell transformation to happen
in the setting of EGFR, for example, you need to shut off first EGFR
signaling before then neuronal programs are activated.
So it could be that FOX2B is an early
player in transformation and leads to inhibition of EGFR, and
then you probably might need other things to sustain
the activation of neuronal programs, and probably also REST inhibition to happen.
And then,
the induction of
ASCL1 and neuro D1 to happen later.
And I think that's also why
we don't see FOX2B.
We see it in a subset of transformed patients, and we lose it over
time because it might be a sign that it plays out earlier in
transformation. But what specifically induces it, we don't know
yet.
Great. Nice work.
Thank you.
Nice talk. Two quick questions, one following up on prior question.
So does FOX2B actually slow the cells down?
So is it inhibiting EGFR enough to slow them down, or do you think it's conferring
EGFR independence rapidly and they keep going?
Yeah. I think in in vitro, it's not conferring independence.
These cells are dying. They're losing EGFR, and they're dying, especially when
we work with constitutive models.
We're trying to switch to dox-inducible models that are able to better
tolerate FOX2B induction at lower levels.
Okay.
But definitely the cells are not...
We even see further downstream MAP kinase inhibition, not just
EGFR, but further downstream EGFR.
And the cells tend to grow slower, but I don't think they
are able to, at least in vitro, to fully be independent of
EGFR signaling. Yeah.
Okay, cool. And then the other quick question.
In de novo small cell,
is there an obvious paralog of FOXB2 that might be doing something similar?
Or do you think it really has a specific role, kind of unique set of target
genes, in transformed?
Yeah, that's a great question. I think
maybe FOX2B is able to activate downstream targets
that are the same as in de novo small cell, but I don't know
what is... Because it's not like we can compare FOX2B to
ASCL1 or further. But maybe something
like SMARCA4 or early upstream neuroendocrine
regulators in small cell that are important and activate
downstream transcription programs.
Okay, cool. Thanks.
Thank you.
Okay. We only have time for a short question and a short answer.
Okay.
I don't know if you possibly just answered it.
So between the
adenocarcinoma and the neuroendocrine,
what actually results in the upregulation of FOX2B?
Is there a particular transcription factor program, or is it suppressed
by something in the LUAD rather than-
Yeah. So FOX2B is usually,
after development, is not really expressed.
It's heavily methylated and not really expressed.
But we don't know what causes it to be upregulated in the transformation process.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Our next speaker is Xuanrong Chen from Weill Cornell Medicine.
Hi. Good afternoon, everyone. My name is Xuanrong, a postdoc at Barbara
lab in Weill Cornell. It has been an honor to be here to share my
project, which is MBD4 regulates FOXA1 lineage specific
enhancers to promote prostate tumorigenesis and
progression. A bit of background that
AR, androgen receptor, is a key driver of prostate cancer.
And AR was first localized at the cytoplasm and upon binds to
its ligand androgen. It will be dimerized and translocalized to
the nucleus, bound to the genome regions.
We call it androgen response element DNA motifs
to regulate the key pathways, which make
it as a key therapeutic target in a clinic.
And it has been also showing that AR reprogramming is a key feature
of the prostate cancer.
It has been showing that in normal tissues, AR binds was
largely restricted to its ARE sites.
However, in tumor tissues, AR binding sites was enriched with
FOXA1 and HOXB13 motifs. And
also has been showing that
in two patient-derived tissues, that AR binds to its ARE sites
was also significantly decreased in the primary
patient samples compared to the normal.
Then I came up with this model that we're thinking that when AR
binds to the ARE sites, it could drive this normal AR
program. However, in a cancer, the FOXA1, the
HOXB13, those oncogenic factors will hijack this
pathway to shift AR away from ARE sites to drive this
oncogenic programs. Then we keep me thinking that
can we find a way to reactivate this normal AR program in the cancer
cells and may kill the cells?
So to do that, we have to find an idea how to modulate
AR occupancy at ARE.
So we came up with this idea. We call it MAC construct, which is a
modifier of ARE-containing chromatin.
So what we do is we take out the AR DNA binding domain,
which can allow this ARE localization to the genome.
Then we link to a
mutant ER alpha ligand binding domain, which can allow the tamoxifen
inducibility and nuclear localization.
Then we hook with three different flavor of chromatin modifying
domains. And first, we have, we call it neutral MAC, which has
everything else but no chromatin modifying domain, which serve as a
control. And the second, we call it repressive MAC.
So this time we use a KRAB domain, which we borrow the idea from
CRISPR-I, which we as a chromatin modifying domain,
which can allow us to achieve this constitutive ARE
repression. And last one, we call it activating MAC.
And this time we use the WEEP64 domain, which again, we borrow the
idea from the CRISPR-A, which can allow us to achieve this
constitutive ARE activation.
Then after we have this construct, we put our construct
into a prostate cancer cell line, which is AR positive LNCaP
cells. And what we can see that upon tamoxifen treatment,
the ARE activation actually kill the cells.
The cancer cell don't like it. While ARE repression,
the cancer cell actually don't care.
And we do the opposite that when we put into the normal cells,
ARE repression actually kill the normal cells.
And to brief summary, what we find that we're showing that
when we force AR at ARE activation, we can
allow the cells to engage this normal-like program, which cancer cell don't like
it. While ARE repression will drive this
oncogenic program. But what drive us further is we
would like to see, is there any switch who can governing this opposing
AR programs?
So what we do is we came up with this CRISPR
screen approach. So what we do is we use this an
epigenetic-focused, the CRISPR screen library, which compose around
2K of the genes, and then we put into our activating MAC
cells, and we treat it with vehicle or tamoxifen.
Then we run the pipeline. And as expected that when you treat it with
tamoxifen, that ARE activation is actually kill the cells.
But you can still get some positioning cells and then collect the cells
and do the comparison, which we can see in this volcano plot that
on the right side, which is kind of aligned with what our
hypothesized, which means loss of these genes could
rescue this growth suppressive effect.
And among all the targets,
MBD4 as my top targets, and I'm
going to show the reason next slide.
And we can also see by this heat map that the small guide,
which against MBD4, was significantly enriched upon the
tamoxifen treatment.
So why MBD4? We have been able to show that
MBD4 expression was significantly downregulated in the
primary prostate cancer samples in both
public available data sites and our in-house data sites.
So next, we would like to see what did MBD4 do in prostate?
Is actually
quite new in the field. So again, we use our
LNCaP, which is AR positive prostate cancer cell lines, and then
we knock out MBD4. We can see that the cell are happy.
But when you overexpress
MBD4, they don't like it. And we also run RNA-seq.
We can see that lose MBD4, you suddenly has high
this AR normal-like program scores while you lost this AR normal-like
program scores. But this effect was clearly restricted to the
AR lineage, which when you knock out MBD4 in
some AR negative cell lines such as PC3 or
DU145 cells, MBD4 suddenly become
essential.So next, I would like
to see what did this happens. So I'm using the knockout cells,
and I run the ATAC-seq, and we can see that upon MBD4 loss,
you suddenly gain this 7K of the genome regions,
and those regions was clearly enriched with FOXA1 motif.
And next, I use my knockout cells, and I run a lot of
cut-and-run, which I have FOXA1, and AR, and three different
histone markers. And I hope I can convince you by this principle
component plots that FOXA1 system changes would amount
the most significant upon the MBD4 loss.
And also we can see that by these differential binding plots that
upon MBD4 loss, you suddenly gain this 46K
size of the FOXA1.
And next, I'm doing the opposite, that I'm using the linkup cell
lines that overexpress MBD4. And we can see that
when you overexpress MBD4, you suddenly lost this 10K of
FOXA1 sites.
So next, I would like to see why did MBD4 loss
could expand the FOXA1 system. But to do that, I have to know where
did MBD4 binding. So this time I'm using a overexpress
model with a FLAG-tag, and I'm using the cells
which I do with the-- Use the antibody which has MBD4
antibody, FLAG, and the IgG antibody.
I run the pipeline, and I was able to
call this MBD4 high-confidence binding sites.
And I was able to show that in two cell lines, that MBD4 binding
sites was largely localized at enhancer sites.
And by two cell lines were also showing that consistently
these are FOXA1 motifs. And we also could
see that at MBD4 binding enhancer regions that up on
MBD4 loss, the FOXA1 signal undergo
significant increase and along with AR signal,
K27 acetyl signal, and ATAC signal.
So next, I'm doing a step back. I would like also to know
what did
MBD4 do in the normal settings? And this time I'm using the normal
prostate organoid model and I knockout MBD4.
You can see upon MBD4 loss, you suddenly form this large luminal
organoids. And also by RNA-seq, you can see that
upon MBD4 loss, you are gaining some
luminal markers such as CK18 and CK8, but you are
losing some of the
progenitor markers such as CHOP2 or PSA-A.
And I can also validate this
by the flow cytometry, which when you lose MBD4, you
are gaining this CD26 positive population, while
when you overexpress MBD4, you are gaining this CHOP2
positive population.
So as a summary that I hope I can convince you today that I'm showing
that by CRISPR screen, I could nominate MBD4 as a
regulator for this opposing AR programs, and MBD4
loss could expand the FOXA1 enhancer programs to
promote this oncogenic program. And I also show that
MBD4 could play a crucial role in maintaining this luminal
lineage specification in the prostate.
And as for the future work,
I'm
also asking myself, what did MBD4 do could restrict this
FOXA1
pioneer function? And it come to me that the
first one is, since MBD4 by name is a methyl binding protein,
it could bind to the methylation DNAs, so is there
something to do with the DNA methylation?
But I think my answer is no, because I'm using my knockout cells and I run a whole
genome BiSequer, and I could see there's largely no
change at those regulated sites. Then I go
back to the literature. Literature has also showing that MBD4 could
interact with HDAC families to reshape the chromatin.
Then I using my overexpress cell lines and run a co-IP.
I do see there is a HDAC1 and HDAC2 interaction.
I'm still actively pursuing this angle.
And with that, I would like to thank my
mentor, Dr. Barbieri, and the collaborators, and the funding source. Thank you.
Now we're open for questions. Nice presentation.
I will start with one. So have you checked MBD4 function
in AR-negative cells?
Yes, we do see that
in AR-negative cells, when you knockout MBD4, it actually
kill the cells. And also in AR-negative settings, MBD4 expression was
also a bit higher. So we have no idea why
it's going up, but it's clearly play a different role in terms of
AR lineage.
I see. So what are core factors you expect to make the difference between
AR positive versus AR-negative cells?
We are still
working on.
Thank you.
There's another question.
Yeah.
That was a very interesting talk.
I don't
think you mentioned this, I might have missed it, but did you look at how
the colocalization of MBD4 with AR?
Yes, they do overlap.
And then, so when you add all of that up together between the
AR, FOXA1, and MBD4, do you see a different
pattern in the context of the cancer versus the normal
prostate cells?
So in the prostate
field, it's really hard to find a normal prostate model.
That's why I came to the normal mouse organoid model.
Okay. Yeah.
Yeah. So it's hard to
find a good normal prostate human model to do the
comparison.
I see.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Okay.
There are no further questions. Thank you very much.
Then we come to our next speaker.
This is
Anne,
I don't know really how to correct, Borja. Thank you.
All right. So today I'll present to you a first-in-class
oral small molecule that targets MYC-driven cancers
by modulating condensates.
So for disclosures, I'm an employee and equity holder in DewPoint
Therapeutics and an inventor of related IPs.
So bimolecular condensates
regulates key cellular functions like transcription by
concentrating proteins and nucleic acids into
functional compartments.
In disease, these compartments can become altered by changing the
composition or the physicochemical properties
of these structures.
And this creates a unique vulnerability that allows us to
selectively target disease cells while leaving healthy
cells largely unaffected.
So MYC is a key oncogenic driver that is overexpressed
or amplified in a wide variety of tumor types.
But despite its therapeutic relevance, it's remained
largely untargetable
because of its disordered nature and its reliance on
multiple bimolecular interactions.
It's become clear that MYC functions
through condensates through evidence both in vitro and in
disease using purified proteins as well as cell
lines and human tissue.
MYC exerts its function through these condensates, and they form
transcriptional condensates with co-activators to drive
oncogene expression. And this opens up a new
therapeutic opportunity
to target the
milieu, the condensates, instead of focusing it
on a specific binding of one
protein.
Today, I'll introduce you to the development candidate
DPX8743, which is a
oral small molecule that selectively dissolves MYC
condensates in disease cells, thus halting
oncogenic transcription and uncontrolled proliferation.
This is an overview of its profile, showing selective
condensate dissolution,
on-pathway activity,
potency correlated to MYC protein levels,
robust activity across tumor types,
activity in animal models, and on-target
engagement in vivo, and an initial promising
tolerability profile.
We identify this small molecule using condensate screening
in highly disease-relevant systems.
Condensate screening is a type of phenotypic screening with a
key difference that we are labeling the condensate as a marker of
disease.
We use automated high-content, high-resolution imaging using an
automated robotic platforms. And then we have a custom
chemical library of 400,000 compounds.
And we use highly miniaturized assays and an
AI-enabled hit calling to identify
the initial hit series.
We then optimize the molecules using
phenofunctional assays. In this specific case, we are looking
for compounds that dissolves the MYC condensates, that leads
to selective cell killing of MYC-driven tumor cells, and
that downregulates MYC target genes.
So this is the profile of the lead series.
The compound is selectively dissolving MYC
condensates in disease cells with high levels of MYC.
This is not happening in healthy cells, which have normal levels of MYC.
And as you will see later in the presentation, this opens up a nice
therapeutic window.
Dissolving the MYC condensates results in MYC pathway
downregulation, and this mechanism translate
into profound antitumor activity.
Here we're looking at a CDX model of ovarian cancer.
Looking deeper into the mechanism of the molecule,
in addition to engaging MYC target genes, it also
engages cell cycle pathway genes.
And more specifically, it induces cell cycle arrest,
halting the cells in G1, reducing the cellular
population in G2 and M phase. And the degree
of cell cycle arrest correlates with
condensate dissolution. We have also confirmed that the
molecule induces cell apoptosis.
So taken together, this data demonstrates that the MYC-C mod
phenocopy MYC genetic knockdown, both on gene expression and
cellular phenotypes.
Selectivity. Here we're looking at a condensate panel of key
condensates of the cell,
and we find that the lead series show a remarkable
selectivity profile,
selectively dissolving the MYC condensates, importantly,
leaving global transcriptional condensates unaltered, as
well as other cellular condensates.In
contrast, the pan-transcription inhibitor seen on the lower panel
here dissolves MYC condensates, global transcriptional
condensates, as well as other key
condensates in the cell important for cell health.
The potency of the molecule is tightly
controlled by two key phenomenon, MYC protein levels
as well as MYC genetic dependency.
Here we're looking at MYC protein levels, keeping the genetic
background of the cell the same. We are just modulating the levels of MYC,
either ramping up the levels of MYC or decreasing the levels of MYC.
And what we find is that knocking down the levels of MYC
desensitizes the cells to the Cmod.
In contrast, overexpressing MYC sensitizes the
cells to the Cmod. So this show that the MYC Cmod
potency on cancer cell killing positively correlates with
MYC protein levels. And this is then in agreement with what
we showed you a couple of slides ago, where we can see the selective
dissolution of MYC condensates in the C
cells with high levels of MYC.
Genetic dependency. So we characterized the activity of the
compound in MYC high dependent cells versus MYC low
dependent cells and found that the compound is
more potent in MYC high dependent cells.
I'm showing you a couple of examples here, but we can also see the same trend
looking at the broader cell line panels.
Patient selection.
So MYC is frequently amplified in various cancers with high unmet
need, but ovarian cancer and esophageal cancer stands out as the
two cancer types where MYC is most frequently amplified.
So that's been our initial focus. But I do want to mention that the
molecules show a robust activity across tumor types.
In vivo pharmacology.
So the compound shows robust anti-tumor activity in ovarian
esophageal cancer models using oral dosing.
Responses include tumor regression and tumor stasis in CDX and
PDX models. And during IND enabling
studies, we will expand on these studies across
multiple tumor types and molecular subgroups to define the most
responsive patient population.
Biomarkers. So the compound demonstrates
in vivo activity and on pathway activity in
vivo. We can see that using tumor RNA-seq from
CDX studies showing
down-regulation of MYC target genes, as well as using
plasma protein profiling, where we can see modulation of
MYC regulated proteins.
Tolerability. So we have performed an initial seven-day
rat toxicology study using oral
dosing, and we observed no body weight loss, no
significant change of clinical chemistry, no significant hematological
changes, no liver or kidney toxicity.
We do observe some thymus atrophy across doses which
will be consistent with pharmacological MYC modulation
and no other significant changes.
And a projected therapeutic index of more than 4X to TGI
of 80% in high grade serious ovarian cancer.
PK profile. So the compound has an acceptable PK profile supporting
oral delivery, has good oral bioavailability and sustained
IC50 coverage. And we are currently advancing a
preclinical formulation strategy which will support next steps.
So with that, I'll summarize. Today, I introduced you to
DUPX8743, a development candidate
targeting MYC-driven cancers. I showed you how the molecule
is selectively eliminating MYC condensates in the C
cells, leading to robust cancer cell killing across tumor
types,
profound anti-tumor activity, including regression
in animal models, on-target activity in vivo,
a PK profile supporting oral dosing,
and a promising initial safety profile, both looking
at in vitro safety and an initial one-week rat tox study.
And the company is now poised to advance into formulation
CMC and IND enabling studies.
So with that, I'd like to thank the Dupoint team,
and happy to take any questions if we have time.
Thank you very much.
We have some questions. Maybe.
Thank you. My name is Melissa from Auric Therapeutics.
I'm
curious, do you have any biophysical data
with your compound and its actual target?
So it's targeting condensates which contain many proteins.
So I'm curious, did you reveal that or do you have such
information of what the actual target is?
Yeah. We have identified the target.
It has not been binding to the MYC protein itself.
It is binding to a couple of targets just upstream of MYC on the
pathway regulating MYC.
Okay. And then I'm not familiar, but maybe you can help
me understand.
When you overexpress MYC, you're also upregulating, increasing
transcription, which is part of what you were trying to show that you're not doing
that globally. Why wouldn't a pan-transcription
inhibitor
... impact MYC condensates?
So a pan-transcriptional inhibitor, as I showed on that condensate panel, will
affect MYC condensates. But the issue is it's not only
affecting MYC condensates, but all the global transcriptional
condensates, so there's no specificity, as well as other
key condensates that are important for cell health.
I thought you showed that it-
Yeah
... did affect the MYC condensates, so that's-
So the reason why we're so excited about this molecule-
Yes
... is that remarkable selectivity for MYC activity.
Next question.
Andrew Bush from Central New Jersey.
Really interesting data. Is it submitted anywhere so
we could look at it a little more carefully?
No, we have not submitted it for publication or otherwise openly,
no.
Okay.
So I wanted to go further on the question before.
So it binds to some one, two, three
proteins upstream of MYC?
That's correct, yes.
And you can't reveal what those proteins are?
We're not revealing the exact targets, but I can tell
you it's binding a few number
of targets that are well-known to regulate MYC
activity. So just upstream of the MYC condensates-
Right
... regulating its function.
Well, then why would it be MYC specific?
If these are upstream of MYC, as you know, hundreds, thousands,
many proteins, many things, drugs affect MYC's
activity. But why is it specific to MYC?
Because you showed it was MYC condensates in specific, right?
Why is there specificity?
It's because of the discovery paradigm, right?
How we identified and optimized the molecule.
So even though we ad hoc look at biochemical assays, the
entire SAR is driven by
cell-based assays looking at the functional
unit of MYC activity, the condensates.
Right. And you're pretty sure it doesn't bind to any part of the MYC protein
itself?
It doesn't seem to be binding to the MYC protein itself, but to the defined set
of targets just upstream, regulating the MYC condensates.
Thank you very much.
Okay, next question.
Congratulations. That's very exciting.
I wanted to ask, a recent paper talk about MYC and
condensate, and there's only 3% of the MYC and targets
is dependent on the condensate itself.
So my question for you is have you seen that similar
phenotype with MYC? How much or what percentage of MYC
targets actually depend on the condensate versus just the
intrinsic ability of MYC to activate target genes? Thank you.
So our molecule is specifically designed to target cMYC.
And as you can see from our studies, it seems
like perturbing the condensate really has
profound effects both in looking at gene transcription
as well as cell proliferation, as well as
tumor growth in animals. So we believe that the
condensate plays a key role in the function
of MYC.
Hi.
Arianna Sabó from Qantra Therapeutics.
Actually, you partially answered my question.
I was curious to understand how the molecule is acting on
the condensate, and you said that it's actually acting upstream of MYC.
What is not clear is
this protein that are the real target, are they regulating MYC accumulation
into the condensate? So after the treatment with your molecule, the
MYC protein will be there in the cells, but no more
concentrated in condensate? Or do you know what's really the
molecular mechanism that is happening?
We have additional insights exactly how it's happening, but we are not
disclosing them at this time.
Thank you.
Gromic Mullen, Foghorn Therapeutics.
So your data where you're showing that a knockdown of MYC
desensitizes the cells to
your compound, could that potentially suggest that the
mechanism is essentially pulling the compound into MYC-dependent
condensates to perform whatever the toxic function of the compound is?
Is this one way to interpret the data? Or how are you thinking about this result?
So we
don't have evidence that the compound is being dragged into the MYC
condensates. That is something we're currently looking into.
It is one possibility. Considering the
target profile of the molecule, we believe it's happening
in adjacent to the MYC condensates
regulating
the kind of functional outcome.
Okay. Thank you.
Yeah, it's true. How does the compound affect MYC protein levels in the
cell?
So MYC is well known to be auto-regulating itself, so it's a great
question. So the MYC compound will also
reduce the levels of MYC.
Thanks.
All right.
Okay. That's the last question, maybe.
Doesn't in tumor cells, MYC auto regulation is lost,
so it's only in a normal cell kind of situation. So you might want to ponder that.
Okay. Round of applause for the speaker and the exciting discussions. Thank you.
Then we move to the next speaker, Kyle Egan, who will talk
about NSD3 is a critical co-factor
that enables fusion oncoproteins driven 3D genome
reorganization and activation of
oncogenic transcriptional programs. Thank you.
Thank you. I'm Kyle Egan. I'm an assistant professor at Baylor College of Medicine.
I appreciate the opportunity to talk about some unpublished work from my lab.
We study fusion-driven cancers and how fusion oncoproteins
regulate chromatin and transcription to drive the aggressive nature of these
diseases.So the
specific fusion-driven cancer I'm going to talk to you about today is a cancer
called NUT carcinoma.
It's a squamous cell carcinoma, which is among the most aggressive solid
tumors. It's found about 50% of the time
thoracically in the lungs, 40% head and neck, and about
10% elsewhere in the body.
It has a median age of diagnosis of 23.6 years, meaning it strikes a
particularly vulnerable patient population in the AYA gap.
And unfortunately, NUT carcinoma has no standard of care.
And due to its exceptional aggressiveness with a median overall survival of
only six and a half months,
it's really important to understand more basic biology about how
this cancer
functions.
Compared to many other tumors which are defined anatomically, NUT carcinoma is
defined molecularly by translocations of the NUTM1 gene, with
BRD4-NUT being the most common. And what is known about BRD4-NUT
function is it blocks differentiation.
Many years ago, we undertook a deep biochemical
approach to understand how BRD4-NUT functions at the chromatin level.
And us and collaborators had determined that
BRD4-NUT coats large regions of chromatin that we call mega
domains, and through a feed forward mechanism where the bromodomains of
BRD4 bind to acetylated histones, NUT recruits the
p300 histone acetyltransferase to result in more acetyl
deposition, which results in more BRD4-NUT recruitment, creates
the spreading of BRD4-NUT across chromatin to form these so-called mega
domains.
We then used high-throughput chromosome confirmation capture or Hi-C to map
chromatin interactions in patient-derived NUT carcinoma cell lines.
And this is just an example of this large genomic data set shown
here, where we're now looking at different mega domains on
different chromosomes. So this would be a domain on chromosome 6.
Similarly, a domain on chromosome 15, where this arrow here is showing the
chromatin contacts between chromosome six and 15, so interchromosomal
interactions. And we're interpreting this to mean that the mega domains are coming
into close physical proximity in 3D space, forming what we call a
compartment in genomics terms. To
ground this more in the cell biology of these cancer cells,
if you stain BRD4-NUT with a antibody or stain the cells with
H3K27 acetyl, they form distinct foci or condensates in the
nucleus. And so we think all this gene regulatory processes are
happening in these nuclear condensates.
Unfortunately, because it's very difficult to directly target BRD4-NUT, we
asked another question to better understand the basic mechanisms of these
altered nuclear organization, or what factors might be cooperating with
BRD4-NUT.
So to first approach this, we reanalyzed mass spectrometry
data from two different cell lines, just simple, naive
293T cells that are induced to express BRD4-NUT, as well as a
patient-derived cell line with a epitope tag on BRD4-NUT so we can identify
common interactors. And we identified many, many
proteins that interact with BRD4-NUT.
But what stood out to us was this protein NSD3.
And we particularly focused on NSD3 because NUT carcinoma is
defined by NUTM1 translocations, with NSD3-NUT
being one of those translocations.
So the biochemical data was agreeing with clinical data from
patients with this NSD3-NUT fusion.
And although this is a very interesting question in and of itself, I'm just going
to focus on the function of NSD3 in BRD4-NUT positive
cells.
So we went ahead and used CRISPR interference or CRISPRi to knock down
NSD3,
getting good knockdown on chromatin.
NSD3 is a histone H3K36 methyltransferase.
It deposits H3K36 dimethyl. When we knock down
NSD3, we see loss of the H3K36 dimethyl
mark, where BRD4-NUT is also bound on chromatin.
And to summarize this on genome-wide, we've normalized each of the mega domains to
the same size, plus a constant amount of flanking DNA, and then color-coded them
for each of the different epitopes that we're profiling by cut and run, seeing
loss of the K36 dimethyl. We also see a reduction of
BRD4-NUT occupancy on chromatin within the mega domains, but
not striking changes in H3K27 acetyl levels.
We then went on to profile how NSD3 might affect the BRD4-NUT
condensates.
And just for the case of time, I didn't have time to show you, but NSD3 is also
colocalizing with BRD4-NUT in condensates.
On the single-cell level, we see loss, obviously, of NSD3 because we're depleting
it. When we knock down NSD3, we see a reduced
intensity of the BRD4-NUT condensates and an increased number of condensates, as
well as for the H3K27 acetyl, which is a second mark to robustly
confirm this. And the way we're looking at this in an unbiased way is to quantify
both the mean intensity per condensate and then the number of
condensates per nucleus. And we see that these two parameters are moving in
opposite directions. When we deplete NSD3, we're seeing a decrease in the
intensity per condensate and an increase in mean number of condensates,
suggesting that the condensates are getting dispersed when we knock down NSD3 in
these cells.
We then, to understand how these two changes relate to 3D genome
organization, we performed Hi-C on NSD3-depleted cells and kind of walk you
through this slide, which I understand has a lot of data on it.
So this is a Hi-C contact map for human chromosome 8, just around the
MYC locus. MYC is actually right here on the far side of this
window. Below the diagonal is the Hi-C data from the
non-targeting control cells with a mirror image above the
diagonal, but this time it's for the NSD3 knockdown cells.
With the cut-and-run data for NSD3 knockdown cells along the x-axis
and the cut-and-run data for the non-target cells along the y-axis.
And just to kind of give you an idea of the scale of the chromatin interactions
we're looking at, we are specifically interested in chromatin interactions
between the BRD4-NUT mega domains, which are these black tick
boxes, which are shown as these black boxes on the Hi-C contact
map. So these are occurring over tens of megabases in this
window.Because admittedly these are very
small and these large maps, we're going to blow up each of these individual
interactions with the knockdown on the left and the non-target control on
the right, where you can see the cut-and-run data consistent with what I showed you
two slides ago. But we're also seeing a decrease in chromatin interactions in the
knockdown sample compared to the non-target control, both here at this locus,
but also at the three other windows within this
region on chromosome eight. We've also expanded the analysis genome-wide
using these pile-up analysis, where we're basically looking at the
signal of the interaction intensity in the non-target control cells versus the
NSD3 cells averaged over all 150 CIS
interactions. And we see about a twofold decrease in chromatin interactions,
which are also then just statistically quantified here, but looking at the box plot
when we're looking at individual contacts.
Okay, so what happens to gene expression when we knock down NSD3?
This is just a simple volcano plot looking at fold-change of gene expression of
NSD3 versus P-value. And we're not seeing tons of gene
expression changes, which I think is a little reassuring that we see NSD3
mostly in the mega domains, not elsewhere in the genome.
And I've color-coded the gene expression changes here, such that the mega domain
genes are shown in purple, which seems to be like there's a bias for downregulation
of the mega domain genes, which is more rigorously shown here with the
GSEA analysis, showing a downregulation of those genes in the BRD4
mega domains. And also using unbiased GSEA analysis, we're seeing
an enrichment for downregulation of MYC target genes, which is
significant for this cancer because nut carcinoma is known to be a MYC-driven
tumor.
Lastly, at a very broad functional level, we looked at
what happens to the cells when we deplete NSD3.
Nut carcinoma cells, as I mentioned, are a very poorly differentiated tumor.
These cells are usually very small cells with very little cytoplasm compared to
the nucleus. When we knock down the cells, the cells flatten, the nuclei become
larger. They upregulate the KRT7 epithelial
specific differentiation marker, and we see a modest
downregulation of cell growth.
So, in summary, we've identified NSD3 as a structural
cofactor that stabilizes oncogenic chromatin organization and
the malignant cell state. It does this by promoting both BRD4
occupancy on chromatin, as well as depositing H3K36
dimethyl. We think it's helping to reinforce the BRD4 nuclear
condensates and to help enable the long-range chromatin contacts that are
driven by this fusion oncoprotein.
It's sustaining oncogenic transcription within the mega domains, which is also
helping to preserve the poorly differentiated state.
And we think that this is an interesting new direction because NSD3 is a tractable
therapeutic. There are small molecules coming online
that inhibit NSD3, both catalytically and non-catalytically.
And we think this might be important due to the lack of standard of care in this
cancer.
Lastly, just wanted to acknowledge the lab.
This work was driven by a graduate student, Yi-Hung Chen, in the lab,
supported by John Collette, Krupa,
Sampat, Adela, Sarah, and Selena, as well as
former lab members. We have a great collaboration with Christopher French at
Brigham and Women's Hospital,
and I appreciate it for funding sources.
And with that, I'm happy to take questions.
Thank you very much. First question, please.
Hi, Jonathan Licht, Van Andel Institute.
Thank you for a very clear
presentation, very nice data.
The looping change is kind of modest.
It's like half down, and so what that means on a
cell basis is the loop formed or didn't form.
It's like you can't half form a loop, right?
So it means some cells are forming a loop and some are not.
And in that regard,
how heterogeneous is the phenotypic response or some cells that
still form the loop, still undifferentiated, ones
that form the loop, whatever changes, and they differentiate?
That's one question. And then what's the redundancy with the other
NSDs? And have you tried some double knockouts or things
like K36M, which kind of blocks them all or things like that?
Yep. All great questions. So yeah, the Hi-C data is population
scale data, so we can't drill down to
sometimes the loop is down. It seems it is about down about
twofold.
But without doing like a FISH experiment to actually look at locus by locus
levels, we don't really know. It's interesting that the condensate
destabilization is about twofold by looking at other measurements, and
the looping's down twofold. It's kind of like things are tracking internally like
that, which was a little more reassuring.
The cell state, this is not, as you saw from the proliferation data, this is not
totally slowing the cells down. We do generally see that
they're in a more differentiated state across the
cell population. In terms of the other NSDs, this is an interesting
question. They're all expressed in
the cells that we've tested. None of them are localizing to the condensates.
We've had difficulties knocking down some of them.
We're not totally sure on redundancy because of that.
But at least in terms of localization, none of them are as clearly localizing to
the condensates or as chromatin as NSD3 is.
Thank you very much. Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm.
I saw that's a very interesting talk.
Just a very simple question. So did you also see the K36
dimethylation to also form condensate?
And then when you try to modulate
the
BRD4 knots, do you also see K36di global
change?
Yeah. So that's another great question. We had tried to do that.
Due to antibody issues, we weren't able to get a successful antibody showing
K36 dimethyl in the condensates.
Okay.
Can I ask a quick question? So what do you expect as a
NSD3 inhibitors compared to BRD4 inhibitors?
Yeah. So this is a great question. So the challenge with
BRD4 inhibitors for this cancer is they're not clinically
efficacious due to toxicity issues, which is generally seen with them.
So we won't necessarily think that NSD3 inhibitors would totally replace them.
It might be a good combination therapy if this actually pans out down the line,
where you can be able to use them at both at moderate doses such that a patient
could tolerate it. But it definitely needs a lot more work.
We're still very much in the early stages for that.
Thank you.
Our next speaker is Hairun Yi.
Good afternoon, everyone. I'm Hairun Yi,
a postdoctoral mentored by Howard Chang and Paul Michel at Stanford University.
Thank you for this opportunity to present our recent work.
And I'm excited to tell you about the hidden link
between the two major hallmarks of cancer, which is
gene fusion and extrachromosomal DNA that we recently discovered.
This is my disclosure.
So if you attended the ecDNA sessions the
couple of days, you might have recognized ecDNA as a
notorious driver of tumor progression, and also poor patient
survival.
ecDNA emerged as a primary location for oncogene
amplification,
and being detected in almost nearly two-third of cancer
types, and in all cancers, the frequency is 17%,
and for some cancer types, it goes around the 50%.
And this frequency goes highly in the aggressive
tumor types.
We now understand ecDNA association with
drug resistance and tumor genesis
by understanding and recognizing how oncogenes are
amplified and inherited on ecDNA.
Unlike chromosome, ecDNA lacks centromere, so they
segregate into the daughter cells unevenly during cell
division.
This creates the massive copy number diversity,
fueling the tumor heterogeneity and also
ecDNA serving as a positive selection platform.
ecDNA poses the great challenges in
clinic for cancer patients, though we don't have the
molecular targets,
and it's remained poorly undefined.
So,
the ecDNA field so far has focused on
DNA level and how genetic information of ecDNA
flows into RNA and protein.
As an RNA cancer biologist, I approached ecDNA
biology with the different angle through RNA.
RNA is not only the messenger but also the regulatory
platform, tuning the gene expression beyond DNA
dosage.
Also clinically, it can precisely inform the actively
expressed genes in patients, and also can be detected
as a circulating biomarker in human biofluids.
So it makes RNA the powerful and trackable window
into ecDNA biology.
Let me introduce one example of RNA ecDNA
interplay that we recently discovered.
ecDNA exhibits the high structural variant, meaning the high
genomic rearrangement across many different cancer types.
Another hallmark of cancer gene fusion is
generated by genomic rearrangement, and once this
happens in important gene, then it can lead to the tumor
genesis. So given the high SB burden
and selection platform on ecDNA, we
hypothesized that ecDNA may generate and
amplifies the oncogenic fusion transcripts that lead
to the oncogenesis.
To test this idea, we annotated RNA and DNA
fusion breakpoints with amplicon type using the paired
whole-genome sequencing and RNA-seq in patient TCGA
databases and cancer cell line CCLE databases.
And this work was done in collaboration with Dr.
Xu Zhang, who's also in the audience.
When we check the fusion frequency, which is calculated by
the number of genes with detected DNA and RNA fusion
breakpoint divided by the total number of genes within the
amplicon, the ecDNA exhibited the highest fusion
rate in both DNA and RNA level.
Not only the fusion frequency, but also ecDNA
exhibited the highest expression of these fusion transcripts,
identifying ecDNA as a fusion hotspot.
Then we asked whether ecDNA is enriched with oncogene
fusions, and the answer was yes. So the most
of the oncogene RNAs, the fusion RNAs that were
enriched over random distribution, which is reflected over
zero in Y-axis, are basically from
ecDNA-containing cancer cells, which is denoted as
red dots in this plot.
So we wanted to check the hotspot of gene fusion on
ecDNA, and we learned that the PBT1MYC locus
stood out the most dominant fusion hotspot
in ecDNA-carrying
cancers.Not only the fusion
frequency but also the PVT1 fusion showed the most
prevalent distribution across many different cancer types,
while the other oncogene fusions tend to be very tissue specific.
Here comes the question, why does ecDNA
preferentially retain this PVT1 fusion?
What molecular features of PVT1 fusion makes this fusion
preferentially retained on ecDNA?
Actually, there have been accumulating evidence of PVT1 fusion in
multiple cancers, but people didn't know about the source
or what this fusion does.
We suggest that ecDNA is the main source of PVT1 fusion,
and the PVT1 fusion transcripts are presented as
lines in here, color-coded by the amplicon type.
The ecDNA is red, and 72% of
PVT1 fusion are arising from the ecDNA-carrying cancers,
showing that ecDNA is the hotspot for PVT1 fusion.
Strikingly, PVT1 fusion shows strong 5 prime
end bias,
showing that over 98%
of PVT1 fusion places PVT1 at the 5 prime end,
and long resequencing of ecDNA immortal cell lines that
express PVT1 fusion show that the PVT1 fusion
transcript retained PVT1 fusion in over
95%.
So what's the meaning of having PVT1 fusion at the 5 prime end of mRNA?
So PVT1 is the long non-coding RNA.
So when PVT1 fusion is fused at the 5 prime end of mRNA,
it can serve as 5 prime UTR that can regulate the RNA expression
beyond DNA dosage.
So this led us to test whether PVT1 fusion can
regulate the RNA expression, and we learned that the PVT1
fusion transcript showed higher expression RNA level
compared to the canonical counterpart over DNA copy
number, and this was attributed to the increased
RNA stability by the PVT1 fusion of exon one.
So how does PVT1 benefit the cancer cells?
To answer this question, we leveraged the most
prevalent PVT1 fusion form in cancer, which is PVT1-MYC,
and we collaborated with Dean Darche lab at Stanford using
their engineered cell line to conditionally deplete the
MYC transcription, and we expressed the
PVT1-MYC or canonical MYC plasmid in the
same amount of DNA. And then we performed a rescue
experiment, and we learned that the
PVT1-MYC more efficiently rescues the cell
viability upon the MYC depletion compared to canonical MYC,
suggesting that PVT1-MYC actually provides selective
advantage to cancer cells, which might be the reason why ecDNA
prefers to have it.
To answer the question how PVT1-MYC fusion could rescue
better than the canonical MYC, we collaborated with Luke Gilbert's lab
at UCSF, and using the targeted single-cell
RNAseq, we could categorize the cells expressing
PVT1-MYC and canonical MYC. And what we learned is
PVT1-MYC expression shows six times
stronger dose-dependent increase of MYC targets compared
to canonical MYC, which means PVT1-MYC more
potently activate MYC downstream targets than
canonical MYC, which explains the higher rescue efficiency.
Together,
this work reveals the new ecDNA-RNA
biology axis. EcDNA generates and
amplifies the fusion transcripts that can provide the selective
advantage to cancer cells. And this
RNA level regulation reinforce the positive
selection on ecDNA, talking back to ecDNA to
retain the functional variants.
So this opens up an exciting avenue to study the functional
variants enriched on ecDNA.
So the insights from this study can inform the new
biomarkers or therapeutic targets of ecDNA-driven
cancers and guide the strategies that can target
specifically the tumor cells,
not targeting the normal cell, where the fusion transcripts are
not expressed.
For diagnostic implication, we showcased using
PVT1 fusion RNA that combining the detection of
fusion RNA with the copy number gain actually
significantly increases the detection accuracy of
ecDNA to 95%.
Beyond the diagnosis, once this fusion transcript can be detected in
the patient samples, then it can inform the
personalized treatment strategy, such as
designing the mRNA vaccine or antigen drug conjugates
to target the fusion peptides.
So I hope that the future endeavor in this area can
accelerate the implementation of ecDNA-borne fusion
transcripts,
contributing to the precision oncology.
So with that,
I want to end my talk with acknowledgement.
I really appreciate my wonderful commenter, Howard Chang and Paul
Michiel, and my collaborators at Stanford and
beyond, especially the Dr. Xu Zhang, who served as a first
coauthor in this paper.And
also, I really thank to the eDynamic team
members and the Cancer Grand Challenge and all the funding
sources. And lastly, I give my thanks to my Lord Jesus for
his great love that renews me and powers me every
day. Thank you for your attention, and happy to take any
questions.
Thank you for the wonderful presentation. Now we open to questions.
I can ask a question. So like these fusion transcripts-
Mm-hmm.
Would they always or under which conditions do they really lead to new
peptides and how does that relate to different cancer types?
Mm, yeah, that's a great question.
So we are working on the fusion peptide profiling and
especially the PVT1 MYC fusion,
we found that actually that can make the neo-antigen
maybe so stay tuned for that. And
as the fusion transcript shows the very tissue specific pattern, I think
the fusion peptide can be also very tissue specific, which can be
also used for precision oncology.
I also like your approach using-
Mm-hmm.
The probe-based single cell sequencing-
For fusion proteins. I don't know if lots of people know this here,
but this novel single cell sequencing approach using these probes
is very powerful. Also now been taking to
even use this for genotyping. So I think-
Mm-hmm.
That can be used a lot and particularly on archived samples.
So I-
Yeah.
Really like that panel, so thank you very much.
Yeah, thank you. We actually really, yeah, got good help
from this collaborator.
Yes. If there are no further questions, thank you very much again.
Thank you.
Then we go to our next
speaker. This is Brennan Papenberg.
Hello, everyone, and thank you for attending both in person and online.
Thank you to the co-chairs, and thank you for AACR for inviting me to
share my project with you. So my name is Brennan Papenberg, and I'm from the NCI
Division of Cancer Epidemiology and Genetics, where I'm in the Laboratory of
Translational Genomics, where I'm a post-doc.
Today, I'm going to discuss a project that started from variation at the TERT locus
and led us to previously unrecognized antisense transcript regulated
by RNA methylation with downstream effects on DNA replication
programs and cancer cell growth.
I have no disclosures.
So TERT lies within chromosome 5p15.33, which is a
well-known multi-cancer GWAS locus.
In genome-wide association studies, we compare the frequency of common
genetic variants between cases and controls, and we look for those that are
statistically enriched in cases.
On a Manhattan plot, each dot is one tested variant, and peaks mark
regions associated with risk.
Importantly, the top SNP at a peak is often a signal for a linked variant
and is not necessarily causal, which is why functional studies are often
needed.
GWAS panels are optimized for SNPs or single nucleotide polymorphisms,
but they often under-capture tandem repeats and other structural variants.
By using long-read sequencing, we can directly visualize multiple
intronic VNTRs or variable number tandem repeats within the TERT
locus.
In our prior work, we implicated VNTR6-1 in intron six as a
proxy for some of these GWAS signals.
And here we're focusing on VNTR2-1 in intron two of TERT, which is a
42 base pair repeat and is highly polymorphic in the population.
Once we prioritize VNTR2-1, we inspected a sequence itself
and asked whether it might encode overlooked functional roles.
On the antisense strand, we found a Kozak sequence and start codon
upstream of this repeat and a stop codon downstream, predicting a
long open reading frame whose length scales with VNTR2-1
repeat number.
That prompted us to ask whether an antisense transcript is expressed from the
region and what function it has. First, we tested whether this predicted
transcript is real and expressed in cells.
We first noticed antisense transcription across intron two in tumor
RNA sequencing.
To validate orientation, we performed five prime RACE followed by long-read
nanopore sequencing, which produced reads mapping to VNTR2-1 in
the antisense orientation.
Finally, RNA FISH visualized VNTR2-1 antisense in cells
with a no probe and knockout controls supporting the specificity.
Together, these assays support VNTR2-1 as expressed as a transcript.
Once we had a validated transcript, the next question was: What within this repeat
might regulate this expression?
Each 42 base pair repeat of VNTR2-1 contains
DRACH motifs, which are the consensus motifs recognized by
M6A writers
such as METTL3 during M6A modification, with a number of predicted
M6A sites scaling with the repeat count.
Since M6A modifications can tune RNA stability and
translation, this suggested an epitranscriptomic mechanism encoded
directly by the repeat sequence.
Next, we tested whether the repeat-encoded motifs are functional.
To do this, we cloned VNTR2-1 consensus repeats into an M6A
deficient CyCheck-2 luciferase reporter, comparing constructs
with intact motifs to motif disrupted
M6A-null repeats. In bladder cancer cell line
UM-UC-3, the M6A intact construct significantly increased
luciferase activity relative to the null construct.
Then, to test M6A writer dependence, we treated cells with
STM2457, which is a METTL3 inhibitor.
STM2457 selectively reduced activity from the
M6A intact construct, while the null construct was comparatively
insensitive, supporting a METTL3-dependent mechanism encoded by
the repeat.Because M6A often affects translation,
we asked whether VNTR2-1AS is translationally competent.
We generated a flag-tagged construct containing the native Kozak sequence,
start codon, and several VNTR2-1 repeats, along
with a matched control in which the start codon was mutated from
ATG to ATT.
On Western blot, the wild-type construct produced a detectable flag signal, whereas
the start codon mutant did not. This supports that the
VNTR2-1AS sequence is sufficient to
initiate translation in mammalian cells.
We then asked whether this endogenous RNA
localization is compatible with translation.
We performed RNA FISH for VNTR2-1 antisense RNA
together with immunofluorescence for RPS3, which is a ribosomal marker,
and calnexin, a rough endoplasmic reticulum marker.
The VNTR2-1AS signal is predominantly perinuclear and is
found in regions enriched for these translation-associated markers.
While this does not prove translation, it places the endogenous RNA in a
translation-compatible cellular context.
With evidence for both METTL3-sensitive regulation and translational competence,
we asked what VNTR2-1AS does functionally in cancer cells.
To do this, we performed RNA sequencing as a
hypothesis-generating screen after altering the levels of
VNTR2-1AS. In our overexpression arm, we transiently
overexpressed VNTR2-1AS in A549 and compared with a
GFP control.
Using RNA-seq followed by gene set enrichment analysis, we observed enrichment
for both cell cycle and DNA replication gene sets relative to control.
To test whether those pathway-level shifts translate to a measurable phenotype, we
used Acceligen's real-time cell analysis.
And when cells are added, they attach and spread, which impedes electrical signal,
and the instrument reports this as cell index over time, with higher
curves representing faster growth.
To test whether this signal is reciprocal, we asked whether deleting the
VNTR2-1 region via CRISPR-Cas9 produced the opposite
shift phenotype. Here we're looking at VNTR2-1 knockout
versus UMEC3 wild type.
In RNA-seq followed by GSEA, we see depletion of cell cycle and
DNA replication pathways
compared to wild type.
Functionally, this corresponds to slower real-time proliferation in the knockout
cells by Acceligen.
And importantly, after synchronization, BrdU incorporation
was reduced in the knockout cells, supporting reduced S-phase DNA
synthesis and a replication-linked defect.
Overall, the transcriptomic reciprocity predicted a growth and replication
phenotype, and the functional assays validate that direction.
Finally, we asked whether that downstream program depends on that
translational competence.
To do this, we compared the VNTR2-1AS flag construct to a matched
start codon mutant.
In the RNA-seq and GSEA comparison, the key point is that DNA
replication enrichment is retained while the cell cycle signal drops out
and is no longer supported by FDR.
That points to DNA replication as the more robust pathway-level output
of the translation-competent construct.
Consistent with that, in Acceligen, the ATG construct shows the strongest
phenotype, while the ATT mutant is similar to control.
This start codon control supports a translation-dependent contribution and
reinforces DNA replication as a major downstream output.
We see that the pathway is more enriched in this comparison compared to the
comparison with GFP.
And the overlapping genes in both of those comparisons are related to DNA
replication, initiation, and stabilization.
To close, here are the main take-home points.
VNTR2-1 is a polymorphic intronic repeat within intron two of
TERT that serves as a proxy to GWAS signals in the region and acts as a
functional element at this locus.
It encodes a previously unrecognized antisense transcript,
VNTR2-1AS, with a repeat length scaled open reading
frame.
This open reading frame contains M6A motifs that are functional and
METTL3 sensitive.
And the transcript is translationally competent and its translation shifts DNA
replication, proliferation, and S-phase DNA synthesis.
Overall, this suggests that a polymorphic intronic repeat at TERT
encodes a layered RNA and translational mechanism that influences replication
and cancer-relevant growth phenotypes.
I'll end by acknowledging the people and support that make this work possible.
I'd like to thank my PI, my lab members, and the collaborators.
We're also looking for postdocs if you're interested in joining our lab.
Thank you all for your attention, and I'm happy to take any questions.
Now we're open for questions. I will start one.
So since this VNTR2 antisense
transcript is located in the TERT locus, how does it affect the
host gene expression?
So we haven't actually seen any changes in TERT expression due to
it. It
is a nested gene, so it's not necessarily necessary for it to
affect the TERT expression.
We are looking more into that. It could regulate TERT expression by opening
up the chromatin, by being transcribed itself to allow transcriptional
factors come to TERT.
At the flip side, it could
inhibit TERT expression by taking up those transcription factors and transcription
machinery.
This
VNTR2-1 has been looked at previously.
That does contain B-box motifs within the repeat as well.
At the DNA level, that has been shown to recruit MYC and other
transcription factors to increase TERT, but we're not seeing any
direct impact from this antisense transcript on TERT expression.
So,
the GWAS, what would be a better approach really to
capture these roles of these antisense transcripts?
Because of course they are not captured as you've shown.
Yeah.
So how could we systematically address this?
Yeah. So the VNTRs and the long repeats are not captured.
Whether or not it's going to be a antisense transcript is something we can
find out later. But as I mentioned, the GWAS
studies are usually fine-tuned to find SNPs, but they do miss
these long repeats. So I think that it's important to
use GWAS as a way to find these signals, and
then further research is going to be necessary to find the long
repeats using long-read sequencing to
try to answer what is causing this SNP to pop up in a
GWAS assay.
Okay.
So we're way ahead of time. So,
first I would like to thank my co-chair, Christopher,
and thanks again all the speakers for your wonderful presentation.
Since we have plenty of time, I will just use a couple minutes to summarize
the talks in this mini symposium. So as
you all know, there are numerous mechanisms underlying the
oncogenic transcriptional control.
And today we covered some of the mechanisms at different
angles in the range of cancer types.
For example, the SOX2 function as a master
regulator in the classical squamous cell
carcinoma through functioning as a super pioneer
factor to affect the chromatin accessibility.
And in non-cancer, the FOX2B was identified
as a potential driver for neuroendocrine
transformation. And also
cMyc is a key transcription factor.
And we all know a transcription factor is not druggable.
However, today I think Anne showcased
how to disrupt the condensation to
inhibit the MYC signaling in cancer.
And besides transcription factors, there are two talks covering the
chromatin regulators, and one is the
MBD4 can refrain the FOXA1 binding to
the lineage-specific enhancers in prostate cancer and the
NSD3 which can be co-opted by the oncofusion
proteins in the LALC carcinoma. And,
in addition, there are
extra chromosome DNA, the structural variant that can
force the genome instability,
and also the novel transcript discussed in
the last talk. I think all these studies not
only provide the novel mechanistic insights but also offer
druggable vulnerabilities to develop a novel therapeutic
strategy against the different types of cancer.
Hope you enjoy the section and thank you all for
participating and great discussion.
Thank you all.